[Music]
looking back today we you know we say
hey we buy the UFC for two million
dollars for you say oh you stole it
I'm not sure we did I'm not sure it was
worth two million when we bought it
Lorenzo Fertitta is the CEO of the UFC
the Ultimate Fighting Championship which
is currently valued at about four
billion dollars he owns it along with
his older brother Frank Fertitta and
their high school buddy Dana White
[Music]
growing up in Las Vegas where there were
no professional sports teams
Lorenzo got to watch a lot of boxing
instead I was really able to see some of
the greatest fights in boxing history
Lorenzo's father started station casinos
in the 1970s Lorenzo and his brother
took the company public in 1993 when he
had just finished grad school so you're
a millionaire at 24 yes yes then a few
years later he bumped into his high
school friend Dana White at a wedding I
think we probably talked to each other
27 times a day since that day so one day
Lorenzo Frank and Dana all went down to
New Orleans to watch a big UFC fight
nobody even knew the UFC was in town and
that's how small as an event that it was
at the time there was no organization
there was no buzz I wanted to go buy
like a t-shirt buy a program there was
nothing but there was nothing there
and it was really that moment and when
we were sitting in our seats at that
fight when me Frank and Dana sitting in
a row we looked at each other and said
either there's something extremely wrong
with us wanting to be here to watch
these guys fight in the Octagon or this
is not a very well-executed business and
there's a lot more opportunity here the
UFC wasn't just unpopular it was also
banned by almost every state athletic
commission and no cable networks would
run the fights the owner of Bob merits
was looking for money to keep the
business alive so I cold called Bob it
was a very short conversation he said he
was looking for a million dollars for
half the business so I talked to Frank
and called him back and said we're not
interested in having partners I'll offer
to buy the whole thing four to nine but
two million dollars didn't get them much
more than a wooden octagon in some
fighter contracts you know for the the
next I would say five years it
is a real grind the brothers spent forty
million dollars trying to make the sport
safer and more palatable we had so much
a pushback from networks when we would
go pitch to them and say hey we own the
USC we want to put fights on TV
how many noes did you get every you
count the network's everybody I mean we
literally got to the point where if we
could have put it on the Food Network we
would have put it on there I mean we
knew that just going out selling fights
wasn't working so we had to change our
strategy and that's where we came up
with the idea of The Ultimate Fighter
[Music]
since they couldn't get networks to pick
up regular fights they made a reality
show where each episode ended in a fight
we like to say it was our Trojan horse
Dana White hosted and the overall winner
got a contract with the UFC the Ultimate
Fighter ended up being the turning point
for the company but to get it on the air
they bankrolled the entire production
themselves and gave it to Spike TV to
run for free and because we paid for it
we owned all the rights that was the key
moment because even today one of the
real points of value in the UFC that we
own a hundred percent of everything
the USC today has earned itself a spot
as a primetime sport and it is watched
by millions around the globe the great
thing about our sport is that everybody
understands fighting and we have the
ability because of that to really appeal
to everyone around the world well we own
the UFC which is the strongest brand in
fighting
[Music]